yeah yeah i mean i had a whale attack
yes
tell me more about this what was the
actual topic
so um we were talking about so i went
with my friend jesse okay
and he would ask the question is it
harder to be black or white in 2022 okay
and he's black so that was like he's you
know that's he's so i'm i'm i'm
the girl right so i say is it harder to
be a man or a woman in 2022
and these the whale thought it was
harder to be a woman okay and i'm like
okay if you lose 100 pounds then it'll
be a lot easier to be a woman
i didn't say that that's what i was
thinking
but
i didn't see that part but what happened
was they were saying well like
first
how would you describe how it started
first the the whale was trying to attack
me
because they were calm at first and then
just got into
um
protection and
oh no i said they're acting crazy
because she was going around to the guys
and saying are you wearing a t-shirt
saying you're going to grate me saying
you're going to grate me are you wearing
a t-shirt that's it and then i'm like
why and i'm like and i started laughing
she's like let's massage the man's ego
and i started laughing and then like the
the sister because like girl the one
whale one future whale but not a whale
yet
and then the the whale was like why are
you laughing and i'm like because you're
acting crazy yeah and then
and then she's like crazy and i'm like
yeah
and then and then
like i forgot what she said she's like
why do you think we're acting crazy like
i can't walk home alone at night without
being scared i'm gonna be attacked and i
said you're not entitled to security
you're not just because you're a woman
like men are more likely to be victims
of a violent crime you're not entitled
to security if you're a guy you can't
walk home alone at night either you just
don't walk home light alone at night in
dangerous areas yeah the entitlement
entitlement oh no boohoo poor me i have
to stay in the house that night
because i might get robbed because i
chose to live in the city of london when
i could live in the outskirts and be
cool exactly but i i mean i made a
conscious choice to live in the a
dangerous area and go to dangerous areas
at night
it's like
it's like
exactly i'm not telling you how to live
your life you know you can do what you
want and then she attacked you she
knocked the mic out of my hand and then
like people had to hold her back she's
like i'll have you you slug first of all
i don't know what a slag is you said so
you're good yeah i know i don't know
but at the time i was like
if you're gonna insult me please use the
word i know right because i'm not with
it i'm not with the tart like
excuse me
yeah
so
all in all 10 out of 10 experience i had
a lot of fun yeah um and then
she was like i'll have you you slag and
i said you're a whale you're a whale
you're a will will sighting
and then i'm like you're 35. and then
she's yelling oh you're a slag you smell
like fish you slag and then i'm like and
i'm like first of all
rude
second of all you're 30 you look like
you're like 35 how are you 35 and acting
like this
you're too old for this
is this my sister's like 15. i thought
it was on youtube before it was yeah and
then she got it taken down somehow it's
still on my friend jesse's channel okay
and i still it just motivated me to post
it on instagram okay because
yeah is it the latest post
something like that this is in shortage
yeah yeah okay so i can see the
suspected whale
whale attacks is the is the title as
well
she looks very angry
oh wow
let's massage the man's ego
you're a whale yeah you definitely
triggered her
yeah damn
the mic didn't break did it no no well
that's good
she was definitely butt hurt by that
everyone said i should have punched her
but i'm like i have more to lose why on
earth would i punch her
you didn't need to do that
she lost as soon as she hit them as soon
as she hit the mic she lost and i'm like
plus like if i really wanted to get away
i could just light jog she'll be too
tired
[Laughter]
oh man
hey good luck yeah the wells ain't gonna
like this
whale attack
yeah so the thing is the authorities
have said to be careful of land whales
right they're angry um
they don't
they're a bit they're hungry clearly
and so and so like you got to be aware
steer clear of them
because
they might get you right as yeah so
they're becoming more and more dangerous
and more and more
more and more aggressive the older they
get this is your first attack
um this is my first i've had some like
minor incidents where
i felt like they might attack you know
i've had a couple non-whales you know
just um
i don't know what should i call the
other ones feminists yeah i've had a
couple feminists where they'll be like
you're disgusting
i'll be like and you're average at best
yeah
we had one we had one girl come here
and she'd been messaging me all week
just like and i said come on the show
let's talk right
she comes and sits down and then leaves
like doesn't even say a thing yeah yeah
she like came in the pot i'm like ma'am
ma'am
speak your piece you've been in my dms
all week
there's oh there's another girl that
threatened to come here and beat me up
with her cousins oh wow yeah that was
another one why
she was mad
that
i used clips from the show okay um
and i said
ish told you before you signed a consent
form there's nothing you can
do
yeah and like because i'm like the
entitlement you want me to not do clips
when i pay a produced like this show
costs money
right and she's like well blur on my
face i'm like then pay my editor to do
it pay me a thousand dollars to go
through every single clip and i blur out
your face yeah do you want to do oh no
no
okay
so you're coming to my business and
telling me how to run it
because you there's a million people on
here just how many people have not gone
viral
how many people have gone on here
had no attention at all
um
a lot a lot
a lot probably more than half right if
you say dumb [ __ ] and people think it's
dumb that's not my fault
i'm gonna make you say [ __ ]
so
yeah so then she like threatened to come
here
with her like cousins or something
and beat me up right but that never
happened yeah well i just said pull up
or shut up and i swear to god i'll sue
you
i sort of gotta touch me touch me
yeah i'm not i'm not playing i'll call
my dad
i don't think she'll be tight enough
no so you could tim hard you know you
could say i'm like in the trenches yeah
yeah the trenches super like tough right
what would you say jess like i'm
trenching it
great
yeah trenchant trench
for you hard for you now i wouldn't say
hard what are you do
you're trenching it
what do you mean for me
for you
for me
for you
the audacity that's not the matter
nothing against you demoted demoted
all right demoted you do my job third
favorite
also we have a new clips channel if you
don't want to be notified every time
we're live but you just want to see
clips turn on your notifications
subscribe to that channel as well